Alex an incredible game back and forth
strategically very complicated from the
beginning to the end tell us a bit about
this game specifically let's start with
this moment when he decided to play C5
change the structure and then you spend
some time here you're trying to figure
things out and decided finally to go for
A3 yeah
I wanted to get to Bishops one way or
another but uh you know against such a
classical strong player that's just a
small advantage and what were your
worries about the position after a take
take or to yet you have the two Bishops
you're playing against the isolated pawn
it doesn't seem like he has a big attack
against your team that's true yeah but I
also know myself I'm I'm not really good
at those technical positions for a unit
slowly to grind your opponent down and
that's exactly what happened I guess he
slowly gradually grabbed the initiative
and I really didn't like my position
because I almost was out it was getting
a bit uncomfortable here yes I'm around
here I was almost running out of moves
but then I finally realized it for as
long as I can keep my night on D4 uh you
were you ready at this point to to make
a draw oh yeah okay you're right yeah
absolutely no I was I was worried that
move H6 uh to Vladimir I didn't like
after the game he said that even though
in a lot of lines the back rank is an
issue uh maybe a rook A3 instead he
suggested that with the idea uh after 94
to uh into laser was it one of the night
goes to D2 probably the C Knight
probably the other one yeah so we keep
F2
we need to B2 right now or B2
Ruby three right
oh whoa okay yeah I know
it's still crazy
yeah yeah maybe forget about it yeah
fundamentally White's position should be
fine because of Bishop on B7 but uh yeah
that's so nice
so much tactics I really felt
uncomfortable oh yeah I mean
but everything could change right and
everything did change as in fact as soon
as two Bishops will get some squares and
diagonals yeah the position might become
real unpleasant for black and uh he
basically is distracted with it
yeah it felt like a bit too ambitious
right my problem was I Rook on the third
rank had no squares to go yeah and the
reason I took an H4 the finally I got
the square on H3
so that's why I wanted to you know to
get rid of this Pawn on G3 and uh and
also yeah he absolutely blundered this
idea of takes takes on Rook G3 and G3
and suddenly the bishop on E8 is
unprotected yet
Alex no he didn't play three I know why
this move appeared yeah maybe you guys
analyzed a little bit after that we just
talked yeah probably that's uh uh what
can I say it's the every half a point in
this tournament coming as a gift and uh
today I got like a great gift from
Vladimir the whole point uh totally on
dessert but it's good before the rest
day exactly welcome the gift before the
rest day congratulations Alex we'll see
you in a couple of days thank you our
congratulations as well as that was a
very nice finish there the Bishops just
took over the position one game